hello everyone and welcome to my talk
about data Centric II
um so first a little bit about me my
name is Marisha I'm a data scientist and
data science educator at got it driven
and today I'm here to talk about
something that I'm very passionate about
which is data Centric AI data Centric AI
is the idea that in order to prove our
model performance we must focus on the
data rather than the model itself
and because of that I want to focus on
two things first of all why is this
concept of data Centric AI interesting
and second of all how you can get
started actually applying it to your use
cases and your problems
so
um let's start with an example of a
typical data science project say we
because of global warming we feel bad
about the Penguins and that they can't
fly so in this case we're doing a use
case where we try to build wingsuits for
the Penguins but in order to build Wing
suits we need to approximate the body
mass of a particular penguin and it
turns out that we don't have that data
so rather than to ask the researchers to
get back into the wild and collect all
the data from penguins different well
spills link suits for we decided to
approximate it because we do have some
other data
um so we have some features the species
the sex The Flipper line the common
length and the common depth
and our initial approach here would be
to try out a couple of algorithms let's
say a linear regression model an svm
nearest Neighbors
and in Tradition in addition to that we
would tune the hyper parameters with a
grid search
so that seems like a very reasonable
approach that should get us some good
results right
well it turns out that our results
actually aren't quite up to par yet so
it turns out that if we look at the data
itself we have some missing big lengths
columns and whereas we initially decided
to drop all the data entries that have
missing data
um that actually ended up deleting quite
a lot of data and it wasn't the smartest
approach
so we try something that we would
normally do for instance we decide to
replace these values uh with the average
of the column so we look up the average
common length replacement values with
that and it already improves our model a
little bit
that's already better but after some
careful exploratory data analysis we
actually discover that there's a
correlation between the sex and the
species and the flicker
so rather than simply replacing the mean
so replacing the missing values with the
mean of the column we decide to replace
it with the mean of this particular
species and sex of the penguin that we
have at hand
and this will probably lead to much
better results because the choice that
we make about our data and how to
replace that is a much more appropriate
choice for our problem
and these are the kinds of decisions
that we make every day as data
scientists we know that modeling is much
more than simply tuning hyper parameters
and that the decisions that we make
regarding our data can have a lot of
influence and our result and our model
performance
whether that is to choose to impute by
the mean or by the mean of the sex of
the species
that actually has a larger effect on the
eventual model performance than whether
you choose to use the genie and entropy
Criterion for your decision tree for
instance the choice about your data is
also has a lot of influence it's not
just about the modeling hyper parameters
or the algorithms
so that's what we say why we say that a
modeling pipeline is more than just the
algorithm it's also the choices that you
make in terms of data transformations
and a lot of these data Transformations
are made very easy for instance in
scikit-learn where a lot of them are
pre-implemented not just with the
missing value computer but also how you
choose to encode your data do you use
one hot encoding or ordinal encoding or
Target encoding
or how you scale your data for instance
or the min max scalar the standard
scalar the Boost scalar so these are all
choices that we make because we know
that these choices influence our
eventual model performance
however
in our Penguins example even though we
made all these data Transformations the
results were still disappointing
and it turns out that upon further
inspection of the data that's one of the
research interns who recorded all the
penguin species measurements made a
little mistake and accidentally recorded
everything so the common length the
depth The Flipper length in centimeters
rather than millimeters
and that completely threw off our model
because no matter how many hyper
parameters you tweak or what data
Transformations you choose if the
underlying data is bad your results are
also going to be that
Andrew noon once said that data is food
for AI but you can do all the
Transformations you want to your data if
the ingredients are rotten your meal is
never going to be any good
and that's also why he said that the
focus has to shift from Big Data to good
data having 50 thoughtfully engineered
examples could be sufficient to explain
to a neural network or the algorithm
what you wanted to learn
and that's why the idea of data Centric
AI is coming
so whereas the original modeling
approach is for monocentric AI is that
we have data Transformations we have our
algorithm we evaluate our model and
based on the evaluation results of a
model we might go back and change some
of the Transformations or change the
algorithm or hyper parameters
the idea behind data Centric AI is that
you go back even further you don't just
focus on the algorithm the hyper
parameters and the data Transformations
you also focus on the underlying data
data Centric AI allows you to iterate on
the data as well rather than just the
model
but why are we so focused on data now
and why is that a new idea isn't that
what we've always been doing after all
this whole motto of garbage in garbage
out has always been the idea
and monitoring your data to discover
errors has been standard practice for
decades and popular techniques in active
learning date back to at least the 90s
so the question is what is different now
that I am here today to tell you about
data Centric AI while we always knew
that data was very important and data
was essential to the quality and the
performance of the model
well think about deep learning
deep learning itself and the algorithms
underneath that weren't a new idea in
2010 2012.
the first perceptron by rosenblad was
actually published in 1958 that
propagation stems from 1986 and even the
first convolutional neural networks were
already around in the early 90s
so the ideas weren't new but the ground
has changed
for deep learning in from 2010 onwards
we had large-scale annotated dates
available we had better hardware and
gpus available and those things had a
massive effect on the Revival of deep
learning so while the idea itself wasn't
new the interest and the hype around
deep learning certainly was because the
ground has changed
and I want to argue that that's also the
case for data Centric AI this is a term
that is now quaint that there's a lot of
attention about the idea that data is
important has always been around but I
think and I would like to argue that
that idea is way more relevant now than
it was let's say five or ten years ago
foreign
for that is unstructured data
for tabular data we can utilize
descriptive statistics quantile
statistics to better understand our data
sets we can create visualizations
investigate correlations between
features to get an idea of the data at
hand before we start modeling
and in this case a simple histogram of
the data whatever field there's
something odd going on with the data
some body masses are suspiciously low
here and if we got this result after
some proper exploratory data analysis
this would naturally guide us to focus
on the good data quality we notice this
easily so it's easy to also do something
with it
however this is something that is
remarkably more complicated when we get
to unstructured data problems like audio
text or images
first of all unstructured data problems
are typically deep learning problems
which means they require much more data
so getting a good overview of the data
at hand is more complex
and second of all it's much more
difficult to get a good Insight in the
data at hand with unstructured data
sure you can sample a few images like
we've done here
but does that really tell you whether
your data is good and representative
in this example this is actually a real
data set that I gathered for classifying
which out of the three penguin species
we have here so there's the three
penguin species gen2 to instruct an
Italy and this data set was sourced by
simply downloading the first few pages
of Google image results
and sure we can see that there's an odd
result in there we see that there's a
report card with a very tiny picture of
a penguin
but it takes a little bit more Focus to
see that the penguin in the middle on
the left is actually not an Adelaide
Penguin at all it has this little chin
strap around its chin which means that
it's a that's a typical characteristic
of the chinstrap penguin
and this is something that we can only
Discover it seems by randomly sampling
some images and my whole data set was
about 5000 images and these are only
nine of them so how can we be sure that
the data set isn't full of these kinds
of mistakes
because we're dealing with unstructured
data now more than ever and unstructured
data is harder to explore
we are in desperate need of tooling and
techniques to help us out with this
and that's also one of the things for
data center AI comes in
and that actually brings me to my second
point the rise of foundation models
traditionally unstructured data used to
be tackled by training a deep Learning
Network from scratch for every single
task and this meant that if we wanted to
train a model that could distinguish
between a car and a truck we had to
fully devise the architecture and train
all the model weights so the model could
make sense of the image
then
once it had an understanding of how the
image must be processed only then could
we learn which images corresponded with
trucks and which ones with cars
however we quickly discovered that
there's a lot of overlap between many of
the unstructured tasks
whether a model needs to determine the
topic of a text or whether the text is
positive or negative in both cases it
requires an understanding of language
and the same goes for images
therefore it seems to lead to let every
neural network learn all these generic
features how language Works what shapes
you can find in an image from scratch
and that's where transfer learning comes
in because with transfer learning we
fine-tune a pre-trained model to our own
data in order to solve a problem
and that means that a model that was
originally trained to differentiate
between trucks and cars with very little
fine tuning can actually be very easily
used to determine whether something is
an image of a dog or cat
and transfer learning can even happen
between various tasks a model may have
initially been trained to predict the
next word in a sentence
but as these models require an
understanding of language with the right
data they can very easily be tweaked to
a completely different task such as
predicting whether a sentence has a
positive or negative sentiment
and that's what we mean when we refer to
Foundation models Foundation models are
very large pre-trained models that can
be used for different tasks with minimal
fine tune so examples include births
tpd3 Dali stable diffusion all these
models that you've been hearing a lot
about in the past year or two
so Foundation models are really large
and in order to perform completely
different tasks they need the right
examples
and it turns out that Foundation models
benefit much more from good data and
from a lot of data
I was initially taught that simple
models especially with a lot of data are
the best at generalizing because over
parameterization was a major concern
but now we have large models that
actually are count for example to that
idea when we provide these very large
models with a few good examples to
fine-tune on it is almost as if we're
overfitting them to our very specific
problem or task
and because Foundation models have
become much more user-friendly and
commoditized
um we as data scientists simply don't
have the resources to compete
when you look at Deep D3 or bird or
resnets the architectures of these
models have an incredible number of
parameters and it is completely
unfeasible for most of us to create and
train those from scratch and we
typically also do not even have those
huge data sets that they were trained on
at our disposal
but because transfer learning you can
still use these pre-trained models and
fine-tune them on our own much smaller
data sets
and that means that the competitive
advantage of the data scientist lies in
everything that surrounds the model
so whereas we don't necessarily have to
focus on the algorithm that much because
that is provided to us with some model
weights it makes much more sense to
focus on the data because the data is
unique to your use case and improving
the data can be easier and have more
impact than focusing on the model
foreign
so a question I very typically hear when
I talk about this topic is but doesn't
quantity compensate for Quality doesn't
a lot of data compensate for the lack of
quality of the data
if we don't have that good data why
don't we just gather more and the model
will learn what is right
because there's this persistent idea
that simply Gathering more data
compensates for the lack of quality
and sure that might be the case for some
problems
but the problem with that however is
that when you're Gathering more data
you're Gathering data in the same way
which means the same problems will
persist
so will more examples of Adeline
Penguins compensate for this one chin
strap I could caught up in the mix or
the paper report card over here
sure probably it probably will if you
gather enough examples of true Adelis
but if you gather more data two things
happen first of all you're probably also
Gathering more bad data
and secondly the model that this was
trained on this data were trained on 10
times this amount of data
will still have the same problems that
the original data set has which is for
instance in this case that none of the
examples here that you see are of baby
penguins because there are no baby
penguins in the data sets and therefore
the model will not be able to identify
them foreign
therefore we must be mindful that when
we gather more data we also gather the
right data
so what is the right data what is good
quality data what is the kind of data
that we would like to gather
um or has in order to solve our
unstructured data problems with
Foundation models
well
first of all the labels of course should
be correct so in this case when you see
a couple of examples of dogs my dog
actually
um there's one picture in there that's
quite clearly
doesn't present them
to confuse the model that it's learning
second of all data labels should be
consistent good data is consistently
labeled this might seem obvious but this
is not always the case and sometimes
it's simply because of unclear
instructions
in this case the labelers were
instructed to put a bounding box around
the penguin but this set me one big
bounding box for both Penguins or for
each penguin individually
foreign
data set should also be representative
that means for our Penguins examples
images from the front the site
individual penguins penguins in the
group on the ice in the water and on
land and yes even a baby penguin
we have to be mindful that all the ways
that we expect to use our models in
practice and what kind of data we expect
to occur there
and lastly a good data should be
unbiased a model trained on biased data
will in itself be biased as well
in this example a clear distinction is
made between the presumed occupations
based on gender and because the model is
not bad in itself but the underlying
data it was trained on was biased and
this is very often the case for language
but also for images and other forms of
data
and there are many forms of bias too
many to tackle in this talk and it's a
topic too complexity right by here today
but there are many tools out there as I
have screenshot here from the data
Centric AI workshop at neurodes last
year that I strongly recommend
so the question is how can we make steps
towards this if let's say you're
convinced your biggest performance gain
is to improve the quality of the data
rather than tweak the model parameters
how do you start
well first of all good quality data is
correct data that means you want to
identify badly labeled data and sure you
can manually inspect the images but
there must be a better way right
one such way is to use a model to get
predictions uh this can be an existing
pre-trained model for instance any model
trained on imagenet will probably have
the label block
uh or alternatively you can fine-tune a
pre-trained model on your initial data
and once fine-tuned you can pass the
data through the model and look for the
discrepancies between the predictions
and the ground truth labels that you
have the model doesn't need to be
perfectly tuned to your data set it just
serves as a guide to what what might
require your attention especially if you
sort these predictions by confidence of
the model it should quickly draw your
attention to the mislabel data points
but even without labels existing
pre-trained models can serve as a
guideway to focus your attention because
when data is passed through a network
whether that's text image or image data
it goes through through two stages the
body of the model which encodes the
input data in some kind of numeric
format that represents the image or the
sentence and its features and then the
head of the task where the encoded
version of the data is transformed into
a prediction
the result of passing data through the
body of the model before it gets
converted to a prediction is what we
call the embedding and your bedding is
therefore a numerical representation of
the input and embeddings can be very
useful to determine which inputs are
similar to each other and which ones
aren't
for example we can visualize them with
the dimensionality reduction techniques
like humor
and in this case our attention is
immediately drawn through to the orange
the dog in the right in the middle of a
bunch of cats
and because this was plotted with the
interactive Altera library that means
that when we hover over the data point
with our Mouse
we see that it in fact represents a cat
so this was mislabel
is this something that you always have
to do manually no because of the
increasing interest in data Centric AI
there are a lot of tools out there that
can help you do these kinds of things
and become increasingly available
one of these tools is the out of
distribution detection from cleanlab
because with just a few lines of code
you can find samples in your data set
that look strange or different from the
majority of samples in your data set
either based on a classifier or their
embedding
in this case the training data was a
subset of c410 only the animal images
and the top outliers that this code
identified amongst the test data were
all non-animal images as you can see
and this approach is based on
calculating the distances between the
embeddings and data points with an above
average distance to the nearest
neighbors are considered out of
distribution
there are even cleanup even advertisers
that they can fix all of your label
issues out of the box by automatically
finding and fixing errors in any ml data
set
foreign
thing however is that you want to maybe
identify ambiguous data points another
challenge for instance this one where
the label was dog but would a model
really be so wrong if it thought it was
a cat
this is also somewhere where you can use
a model or the embeddings
in this case by using two models each
model was trained in such a way that it
picks up slightly different things maybe
because the architecture was different
or the data that it was trained on was
different
and again it's the discrepancies that
you're interested in so if one model
thinks this is a dog the other model
thinks this is a cat
that is an interesting data point for us
to manually investigate
or we could look at one single model and
simply look at the decision boundary
um images in this case that model was
less certain about is it a dog is it a
cat those are more interesting for us
um so then it is up to you to decide
what you want to do with these data
points maybe you want to get rid of it
because it's a bad example maybe you
want to put it in your validation set
the choice that you make is up to you
but the tools like this help you
identify the interesting data points
and that brings me to my next point it's
also important to carefully craft your
train and test split
so for structured data that's very easy
with scikit-learn but for unstructured
data it's important to carefully craft
your training test splits because the
distribution of your training or test
set have to be similar
so one of the ways to do that is through
profiling your data that is easy for
tabular data like fundus profiling
but it's also something that you can do
for your image data for example with a
tool like ylocks which is a data open
source data logging Library
in this case you see information about
the images in your data set and for
instance you can see the distribution of
the blueness of your validation set
versus your training set which can lead
you to believe that there are more
images of penguins in the water for
instance in the validation set compared
to the training set
but again I like to focus here on the
embeddings
um because that tells you a little bit
more about the content of your data
because there are representation of the
numeric input
um
yeah so by retrieving the embeddings and
plotting them and comparing your
training sets to your validation set you
can see for insert and then disinteract
people the foundation set was missing
quite a lot of the stuff on the on the
left here
and my advice would be to focus on the
validation set quality make sure that
your validation set is complete and
representative
um it doesn't matter how much you tweak
the model or the data if your validation
set is bad you won't see the difference
so make sure that your most difficult
examples for your model are in your
validation set and not the easiest ones
and that brings me to my last Point make
it easy to iterate on your data
um whatever you do make sure that it's
easy to version your data and change
your data and that can be through
low-tech tools if you see here in an
example where we simply use Google
Sheets and a bunch of images to relabel
but that could also be with high-tech
tools like data Version Control or or
building pipelines that allows you to
easily re-label images it doesn't matter
which tools you use whether that's high
tech or low-tech as long as it's not a
burden to make quick changes to your
data
foreign
how to get started identify Incorrect
and ambiguous data points and labels
focus on carefully crafting your
training validation set make sure that
they're representative of your real
problem and focus on the quality of your
validation set above anything else
and lastly make it easy for yourself to
iterate on your data sets version your
data easily relabel your data whether
that's with low-tech tools or with
high-tech tools but don't let that be a
burden
and in summary don't treat your data
sets as static
so that was my talk
um I hope you enjoyed it feel free to
reach out if you want these are my my
details and um back to you I would say
um hey maricio I think we've got about
like two or three minutes left and we
can select a question to answer I just
like pinned to the to the Stream
as uh as the question described was
there any um
were there any
um like tools you'll be recommend you
could be you could be like
recommendating to people who are looking
forward into this idea yeah
um so the problem with this is uh we
like to focus on creating more tools to
make things easier uh for us but at the
same time the whole the whole idea is
that your use case is unique so it might
not be the case that a tool that I like
to use is also good for you your use
case there are a lot of really good
resources out there there's the why data
also data Centric AI uh list of all
kinds of tools and there's one by hazy
research that I can also recommend it
just gives a list of all these different
for instance labeling tools for
different uh for different types of data
and you kind of have to mention and
listen and mix and match what works best
for you
um I would simply advise you to look
what's what's uh what works good for you
and to keep a lot of the control with
yourself so for instance I really like
that cleanlab has this out of
distribution detection and I use that
but I don't really like to use the whole
fix all the errors in one go pipeline
because I don't know what's happening
then and what's happening to my data and
I lose a bit of control there so I
personally like to look for the tools
that do the specific thing that I want
but not one thing that does everything
in one go
but again why data and hazy research
have a really good list of tools out
there that provide a good start
all right I think that will be all and
um thank you for coming that was a great
talk by the way
um right thank you for having me